the average cow can weigh as much as
several people so holding it still for
medical procedures would be a challenge
if not for a device called The Squeeze
shoot the walls of this special stall
immobilize the animal from head to tail
while multiple openings allow access for
treatment a squeeze shoot is all about
restraint it holds an animal still for
medical and other procedures so that no
one gets hurt
[Music]
key to the design are a front gate that
closes around the animal's head and a
cage-like structure with a squeeze wall
that contains the rest of the body
production starts with a big coil of
Steel as it unwinds rollers straighten
it and a blade cuts it into
sheets the sheets head into a laser
cutting station the laser cuts out the
same part numerous times producing many
from one sheet it's all computer
controlled the part being produced is a
component of the side exit
gate they form more steel into tubing an
operator then loads the tubing into a
bending machine it wraps it around dyes
to shape it into one of the shoot's
access
Hoops it cuts the ends of the hoop and
ejects
[Music]
it an automated system transfers the
Hoops to a rack
a worker arranges the Hoops on the upper
half of one of the shoots SED frames The
Jig serves as a template for the
placement of the
Hoops he welds the bottom of the Hoops
to hinges on the
frame these clips are for opening or
locking the
[Music]
Hoops he welds one to the top of each
access
hoop to vaccinate an animal the operator
can simply reach through the Hoops if
greater access is needed the Hoops can
be
opened he assembles a panel to the
bottom of the second side
frame he welds Clips to the top so that
this panel can be opened for access to
the lower part of the
animal he hinges the panel to the base
of the
frame next a machine bends steel tubing
against a circular
form after the first bend the worker
repositions the tubing so the machine
can make the second one in the correct
location the tailgate frame has taken
shape with the frame in a jig a worker
welds vertical bars and diagonal
linkages to it he also assembles a metal
shield to the lower half to keep the
cow's hooves safely
inside holes have been drilled in both
ends end of the Chute floor they'll be
used to move one wall inward to tightly
contain the
animal they erect the chots steel
skeleton with a hoist for help the
worker transfers the tailgate to the
structure with the lift supporting it he
guides the top onto the squeeze shoot
[Music]
framework he welds the structure
together the next part is the squeeze
wall he attaches it to the
structure he opens the tailgate to test
the clearance and assembles a steel
panel to the lower half of the squeeze
[Music]
wall he mounts the other side panel with
the exit gate to the
[Music]
structure he hinges it to the tailgate
frame and welds it to the frame at the
top he pulls the lever to verify that
the side gate operates
smoothly he opens the tailgate again to
check the
clearance he then moves the squeeze side
through the various settings he makes
adjustments if needed to ensure that the
squeeze wall is properly aligned at each
Notch with multiple access points there
are many ways to approach a steer in a
squeeze shoot they dip the entire
structure in a paint vat this ensures
even
coverage the headgate has been specially
contoured to hold the animal's head in
position the employee slides rubber
grippers onto the operating
handles and he applies the brand
[Music]
Graphics this squeeze shoot is now ready
to immobilize the Chute locks the animal
in position and it has has no choice but
to stay
still until about 30 years ago boat
propellers were mainly made of steel or
aluminum then they tested the waters
with composite propellers made from
nylon resin and fiberglass they're
lightweight and don't corrode and in
certain models broken blades can be
replaced with composite propellers the
there's another way to move forward on
the water these props are the latest way
to convert rotational motion into
thrust production starts with a computer
design this one is for a houseboat
propeller the design will drive the
Machinery that manufactures the
molds this is the raw material pellets
that are half fiberglass half resin they
place them in a dryer to remove moisture
the operator takes a sample of the dried
pellets he weighs the pellets and then
Heats them to evaporate more moisture
the difference indicates how much
moisture has been removed the amount
that remains is very
small they'll now use these two-part
metal molds to form the pellets into
propeller
blades it's a process that takes just a
minute and a
the molding machine melts the pellets
and a large feed screw forces the molten
material into the mold the composite
material solidifies and the operator
removes the newly formed propeller
blade the process leaves a piece of
unwanted material known as the sprew the
sprew is composite material that
hardened as it flowed into the mold once
cut off it falls into a bin to be
recycled reced into the next composite
propellers the trimming of the sprew
turns the propeller into a functional
part they'll mold composite material
around an aluminum core to create the
Hub The Hub fabrication starts with an
extruded bar of aluminum which a band
saw cuts to size each piece will serve
as one
core using a tool with a sharp curved
blade he trims off the little rough bits
left by the
saw these rough bits are known as Burrs
so this process is known as
deburring once the edges are smooth he
attaches Clips to the three
Wings these clips will be used to Center
the core in the
mold the worker slides the core into the
mold and the clips hold it in a precise
position he activates the machine molten
fiberglass and resin material flows into
the mold cavity and encapsulates the
aluminum
core it also forms channels for the
insertion of the propeller blades
trimming will fine-tune the
shape a computerized milling machine
moves the Hub into position for
trimming a computer-driven drill BS into
the center to open up the hole
the next operation will carve teeth that
will make the corresponding ones on the
motor shaft this is called broaching a
machine pulls a spiraling tool called a
brooch through the center hole of the
Hub the tool carves through the
composite layer and into the aluminum
core to cut the
teeth here's a close-up look at those
teeth
now it's time for all the parts to come
together the assembler slides the blades
into the grooves in the hub the grooves
hold them precisely in
place he Taps them with a hammer to
further entrench
them a part called a rear cap finishes
it
[Music]
off for an inside look they've cut a
propeller open the cutout reveals how
the composite material has become one
with the aluminum
core and now a test the technician
attaches a chain to a blade and using a
hydraulic ram applies pressure he
measures the breaking point at 1 and 1/2
tons of force it's
significant if a blade breaks a new one
can be installed in the
hub this composite boat prop tell has
taken about 20 minutes to manufacture
once attached to the motor shaft it
should last for years the fun has only
just
[Music]
begun